okay
playing chess is very fine
we'll go into a french why not
this is a line that i had prepared in
reykjavik
a6
i'll admit i don't remember so much
theory i think a3 is okay
and the point is to play b4
it's a risky looking line this knight's
undefended
and there's some idea of bishop e3
and it's been a while since i reviewed
these lines
wow knight d4
d4
and bishop e3 looks tempting
although there's takes in d4 wow
bishop b2
so the point of this line is white
stacks upon and then
black is a bit behind development
so it's a gambit
but it's been a pretty recent trend like
high levels
wow
it takes takes
preventing the stuff
bishop d4
i mean f6 is intention
[Music]
rt1
hmm
some idea playing g4
if ever g6 and knight comes in
there's this move
i can take
hmm
ah there's rook c5
or that
i'm in trouble
let's go
let's go
oh no my queen i didn't even have time
to say oh no my queen
i wanted to say oh no my queen
but my opponent took it before i could
say it
wow
okay i was dead that game
i was really dead
black played well to
like almost destroy me
just in the final moments
what a game
why is my heart rate so low
maybe i'm already cooling down
i didn't get a chance to see my peak
cart right there
yeah i thought this sacrifice was
dubious but this was a strong follow-up
because i had a lot of loose pieces
like both bishops my knight my pawn
a very delicate position
[Music]
i spent most of my time here 38 seconds
i spent
so much time
and then
the f4 should be just winning
but
there's another line here here
and at first i saw queen h1 bishop g1
and maybe white's holding on
but there's rook c5 here
threatening mate
yeah i only saw the potential mate
coming
maybe around here
like i saw the potential for the pin
and i was trying to find like figure out
the trickiest way to set it up
because if i play this move
oh maybe this also sets it up
because if takes takes takes it's mating
but black wouldn't have to take
so the the best way to provoke black to
take was to
leave both things hanging
um
and either either a move gets mated
instantly
simple move would be queen g2 deflect
the rook and then take the queen
or anything else like making luft
the swindler strikes again bravo on a
last second oh no my queen sack for the
win good sir